what would life be like if you could live to 150
healthily what about 200 what about beyond that
well it's a very interesting question
a question with profound philosophical
moral ethical psychological environmental
and economic implications but for today's
guest a very interesting russian chemical engineer
turned investment banker turned venture capitalist
it's not merely an academic thought experiment
because cutting edge breakthroughs are very much
on the horizon his name is sergey young he's the
founder of the 100 million dollar longevity vision
fund he's an xprize foundation board member and
a development sponsor of the age reversal xprize
which is a global competition designed to find
a cure for aging he's also the author of the
brand new book the science and technology of
growing young which is a really fascinating
demystification of the longevity landscape
it's a look in the near and less near
future of advancements and possibilities that
await us and the many practical things that we
can and should all be doing now to live healthily
to 100 and beyond why am i telling you all this
because he is right here right now on this very
podcast so please hit that subscribe button and
let's do this this is me and sergey young
heading down the longevity rabbit hole
sergei nice to meet you thank you for doing this
driving up here been looking forward to meeting
you reach everyone it's uh it's good to have you
i'm very excited excited to talk about all this
kind of stuff but before we get into any of this
i got to know i mean i can't believe your last
name is young yeah as somebody of russian
descent that can't be your real last name
so you have a stage name yes i do uh so and when
people ask me about that i'm really upfront so
this is the truth i started to spend a lot of time
in u.s in the last five years since i've developed
a passion to change the world and and u.s is a
biggest inefficiency that we have healthcare-wise
it's like the most inefficient healthcare system
in a world with 18 percent of gdp spent on
on lifespan which is constantly declining in the
last five years so and then i so i use my russian
family name and then the whole conversation like
every first 20 minutes of every conversation was
what about your leader what about the country what
about vodka what about uh bears on the street so
can i have this conversation yes i can right
so but then you start with almost like negative
consideration and then you turn it to neutral and
positive and it's like hard work on the first 30
minutes of every conversation and it was pretty
detrimental for my mission right because what
i want to concentrate on about bright future
what we can do today what are the choices that
we're facing today rather than explaining this
whole russia story so what i thought uh and i i
was just looking at tony robbins who said i've
created this tony robbins guy so i google him
so apparently his family name is not robbins oh
i didn't know that okay that was the case for me
and i thought well if tony can do it right what
i've so i and i met a beautiful uh chinese lady
when we were discussing age reversal x prize
competition and her family name uh was young
i am married man so i just bought the name for
her and i'm like you have a beautiful family name
and she said well come on sergey we all have like
our different names here because i will if i will
run on my link 1 4 it's just very difficult to
integrate into the culture so i thought okay
i can do it as well so what i've done and for
russian men to change the family name it's it's
like it's a big decision so what i've done just to
uh i gotta make it comfortable for me i registered
a trademark sergey young i'm 100 uh owner of this
yeah and um and i just give myself an opportunity
to use that so that's that's the story listen
you're in you're in los angeles right now oh
yeah this is like this is yeah ain't nothing but
a thing here yeah yeah but again and it's it's not
something that i hired from but it's it's really
turned my conversation from explaining the past to
create in the future and and this is what i wanted
to do right so we're going to get into all things
longevity the near future the crazy latter future
that awaits us the current state of affairs and
all of which is broken down beautifully in in your
new book growing young which i'm really enjoying
it's actually a much breezier read than i was
expecting like that you have your scientific you
know rabbit holes that you go down from time to
time but overall um it's kind of a page turner for
the subject matter that you're tackling with all
of this it is the biggest challenge was to just
to keep it simple and we we literally um took
out the chapter on theories of aging because
in the end of the of the day we don't have like
the theory and it was 40 pages of hard science
so in the end we just end up with explaining
the hallmarks like what are the roots of aging
and confirming that we still don't have an answer
yeah well aging anti-aging longevity are themes
that we've explored pretty extensively here on
the show i've had your friend david sinclair
a couple times and i've had dan buettner the
blue zones guy here like we talk about this
a lot but one area that we haven't
really kind of cast our glance on is this
future imagining that the book opens up with which
is right out of a movie like walk me through like
to me it feels quite pollyanna but i want to hear
your perspective on on this sort of optimistic
perspective that you have on how all of this could
play out in the next 50 100 200 years yeah um okay
so i call it fall horizon or like horizon
3. so well first of all i must say that
i'm waiting for this with combination of
excitement and fear as well there's so many
things that we need to solve on this planet before
we actually can enjoy living in a human body 2.0
version so but so that's one two is is is a bit
far away it's 25 to 50 years from now it's we we
don't need to decide you know everything on how
it will look like but when i see the future it's
a future when we will have an opportunity
to redefine what human body and mind means
and for me it's it's a very positive problem
so we're gonna switch from biological view of
human body into more engineering view like an
all-car metaphor when you can extend resource
of the old car just replacing like the parts so my
future is about our ability to regenerate organs
ability to alter our genes when we and
we already know 3 000 genes in our dna
which are responsible for aging processes which
starts probably after age of 20 25. in our life
my future is about internet of body when we are
full of sensors who are helping us to prevent
diseases by identifying the very early stage
of it like a cancer cancer or heart disease etc
and we live in there so we we already have some
wearables yeah you got a bunch on you yeah i have
yeah yeah you're covered in yeah so purple
technology that's a zeo patch right so that's
um what does that mean so basically it's it's
just doing electrocardiogram of your heart
for seven days in a row and it's very reliable
way to monitor your heart performance rather
than one of akg that you can do it's um well
it's just seven days and nights of your hard
work uh so you just it's re recorded here on
the ceo it's not it doesn't sync to an app on
your phone well like that not yet potentially in
a few years time there's there's no uh obstacles
for this to integrate like you know have glucose
monitor here and i'm not from levels do you have
the levels uh yeah i'm actually i i order levels
uh but right now i think it's a different producer
i just had my annual checkup this tuesday i'm 49
everything is fine i can run another 151 years
but then so coming back to your question rich so
for me the future is also about internet of body
about our ability to detect uh the disease
before it's even manifest itself develops
itself my future is about helping people who are
suffering today from neurogenerative diseases
by supplementing and helping their brain to
work through brain computer ai integration
so for me it's not a cyborg thing for me is uh is
an opportunity to help people in their like 80s
90s to actually have a clear mind and enjoy
their life not to be in a fragile stage and
well the other piece of it is human avatars we are
longevity vision fund in my font which supports
affordable and accessible version of longevity
and digital health we look at few human avatars
projects but we still undecided whether it's going
to be like robotic avatar route or virtual avatar
because virtual it's just much easier to replicate
ourselves in a virtual world i i just couldn't
really accept that as a person as a human being
so i would love us to stay in the real world
but um well that's uh that might be there so
there's there's plenty of things which gonna
happen well i wanna walk through all of these
technological advances um in in in a serial
fashion but before we wade any deeper into this
perhaps we should define our terms a little bit
yeah you know how do you think about longevity
because that means different things to different
people yeah that's true well remember i'm really
interested in developing a solution which are
accessible for as many people as possible so my
definition of longevity is intentionally broad
whatever increase the average health span
and lifespan on earth is longevity for me
and there's a lot of reasons behind that partly
because aging is not considered as disease
in official terms so you couldn't really
invest in aging and have your investments
protected pay off your billions of
dollars if you want to invest in that
but partly because you need to be intentionally
brought and work with a health span to make sure
the ears that we add to someone's life are
healthy and happy years and not necessarily
like you just said in five to ten years in the
end of that so that's my definition of longevity
so in terms of kind of where we're at right now
and what we're on the cusp of there's a variety
of buckets here um and it's super interesting
you know you're talking about your wearables
you know i'm wearing a whoop strap i think you
have an aura ring on yeah i don't know you would
have four three or four well you also have an
apple watch so that's doing whatever it's doing
we're only going to see the expansion of
these devices in the refinement of them
until we reach some inflection point where all
our biomarkers are not only getting tracked in
real time they're getting uploaded to
some cloud and they're being computed
alongside these other massive data sets the
numbers are getting crunched and some ai is
getting a really refined glimpse or picture of
what human health is and that of course leads us
into this new field of not only early detection
but early diagnosis and the ability to kind of
catch things before they even get to a certain
point where they become malignant or problematic
for the human body when you have a less well
pretty lower chances of recovery like stage four
cancer is probably 20 to 30 recovery rates stage
one like early detected cancer gives you 93 to 100
recovery chances so that's the case but i
mean you're right this is the future that we
aiming for we're working towards so with that
i mean there's all sorts of there's a whole
ethical you know sort of discussion that
i want to have with you but we can kind of
table that this is my favorite utopia yeah i love
morality or immortality no this is yeah this is
that i read that chapter twice because this is
what i really want to talk about with you but
um what is what are we looking at in the next
you know five or so years in terms of where
this wearable technology is because it's some
of it's better than others um you can tell that
this is in a you know to kind of extend the age
metaphor in its embryonic state in terms of its
maturity and its ability to really provide
you with accurate information that's that's
that's uh that has a practical application for
the individual obviously the data is what's most
important to the companies that are creating these
but in terms of of how we use this data to improve
our lives like where is that heading and kind of
what's next in terms of what we can expect well
let's that's just a lot of thoughts around this
question so one is one third of the world data
is health care related well that's a lot right
and and this is great it's a great opportunity
second is um well it's an uh it's almost like
an anecdote i think it was uk health regulator
who just prohibited the purchase of fax machines
for hospitals and like when was the last time you
i mean you've seen fax machine that's that's more
of a glimpse into like where we're at in terms of
yeah well let's start well that's again every risk
is an opportunity so both in the us and uk up to
in some of the cases up to 70 of the data transfer
is happening through fax machine and it's i think
it's ridiculous yeah it is so in the future
data is an opportunity and i do believe that
and i'm always saying that the
largest health care companies on earth
in 10 years time gonna be amazon apple
sure uh microsoft or whatever the big tech
uh who are interested and and engaging in the
healthcare space so the change will come not from
us or the old players doing new things the
change will come from new players doing new
things well and that's exactly the beauty
of wearables and its ability to collect data
and then store it in cloud and then artificial
intelligence pre-analyze that so i i think about
like wearables though that we have i do believe
that in the next two to three years we'll add few
um important features to measure like our glucose
to measure our blood pressure and then if you add
it to what what you can measure today well that's
i do think it's 90 to 95 of the health data you
need to measure on ongoing basis about your body
uh there's this little human interaction needed
in actually analyzing all of that even today
early like liquid biopsy early cancer diagnostic
companies just run exactly the same procedure
data cloud ai and then feedback loop to you
and well that's i i do think it's an
opportunity and it's going to be much more
kind of friendly um integrated version
of wearables for all of us and again uh
this will help us to fight uh as i call
killer monster diseases like heart disease uh
cancer diabetes and it's probably after age of 50
this uh these three diseases are responsible for
about 70 75 percent of that so and they're all
preventable moreover the cost of all of this gonna
decrease exponentially so we at longevity vision
fund when we invest in technologies like this
the optimization gain is not 10 to 20 but 10 20 50
times against car and technology so it's much more
efficient and cheaper version of the healthcare
and the paradigm going to be like super preventive
super personalized rather than one size fits all
at ridiculous prices i feel like the pandemic
uh really accelerated this process
no like gasoline on this fire from
telemedicine to obviously the introduction
or the the the heightened interest of the
tech giants getting into this of course
amazon being you know the obvious oh yeah
player who's going to move in here in a big way
i just know from wearing a whoop strap like oh
the you know you get emails like pay attention to
your respiratory rate if you see a wild swing like
that could be an early indicator of being sick and
i think this is only going to be more ubiquitous i
mean levels when you look at it they're predicting
something like 30 of americans are going to be
diabetic or prediabetic by 2050. so blood glucose
monitoring is going to be just basically something
that most people are going to be doing especially
as the price point comes down yeah yeah well
that's amazing and if you look at the whoops of
this world this will transform itself from being
like activity tracker to our very own personalized
healthcare device so that's why you know i'm
i was not a big fan of wearables even three to
four years ago i really just forced myself to use
it like ordering like whoop that you having just
to make sure i i start to collect the data and
form like a database of my own health indicators
so this is just going to change our ability to
uh control our health but also it gives
us an opportunity to take responsibility
back because think about this i do believe
like 95 percent of our health choices today
are delegated to other companies and other players
and they're not necessarily doing this in our
own interest from regulators to you know big food
producers health care providers the overall health
health care system it's a sticky wicket i mean
it's a tangled knot of vested interests and
cronyism and just a massive byzantine bureaucracy
that you know well-intentioned politicians are
always trying to you know make malleable and
always come up short i mean i know that's a
big part of your mission is like how do we revamp
healthcare how do we create a system that that is
compatible with this modern age and the power of
these technologies that we have to revolutionize
how we think about not just aging but preventing
and and diagnosing and treating disease
yeah i agree with you and what we have today is i
call it the system of collective irresponsibility
because no one is really responsible for making
sure you have healthy choices along your life road
and and it's partly because we don't feel
that we can manage that and i do think the
the arrival of wearables of more data-driven
medicine give us this opportunity to feel in
control to feel responsible for health choices
yeah i mean so much of it is environmental
though because those healthy choices are not
as easily accessible as the vending machine
or the drive-through oh this is my biggest
pain right and and it's and i do think it's
it's really unfair to the people specifically here
in the u.s right when we spend 18 percent of gdp
on healthcare again three at least three out
of last five years lifespan was decreasing
we're like the only developed country on
earth which has its lifespan decreasing and
what is happening like 70 of um antibiotics is
consumed not by people but poor animals animals
yeah and and so i just had a chat with uh with the
ceo and head of science at human longevity center
in san diego when i do my annual checkup
and and i was just asking guys what what
is your biggest worry about u.s nation and
i kind of thought it's a sugar because we
just consume enormous amount of sugar against
our interest in the form of um well different
foods but mostly sugar drinks and to my
surprise they said you know what sergey
the the biggest problem is actually antibiotics
resistant developed by the fact that people just
have still have this habit to consuming
meat and fish which is made in very cruel
uh industrial terms and has things which shouldn't
be there like growth hormones antibiotics equally
bacteria and and it's so caloric intensive it
actually works against your longevity because
there's a lot of disagreement in in the science
world what actually today would actually give you
an opportunity to extend your life uh but there's
almost one agreement that that decreasing your
calories intake uh is the best way to add at least
two four five healthy and happy years and like
just consuming this whole animal protein thing
increase your calorie intake by what 50 to 100
so if you on a plant base well that's like the
easiest way for you to manage this whole thing
without torturing yourself with like everyday
choices can i eat that or not i'm so for me
default choice i'm like as plant-based as possible
because even if i'll eat like a half of this table
of vegetables i'm still going to be fine and
there's it's just healthy on on so many fronts
for your mind and your body so i run on vegetables
all right you now you're speaking my language okay
yeah you know let's do it i'm all about that so
we're on the same page as far as that as far as
that is concerned i'm interested in how i mean you
have a you have a lens on the us healthcare system
you know where we've gone awry how does that
square with with how russia handles it like what
the difference is there yeah so yeah i'm more
knowledgeable in how it's done in uk because
i'm part of um uk parliamentary group on national
longevity strategy and singapore because i have a
lot of friends i'm actually doing a presentation
on on in july to singapore authorities to make
the first countrywide longevity program for the
whole country i'm actually my resolution for this
year to find a country which i can change and
so that's why i'm working with uk and singapore
um well singapore spends five percent of its gdp
on healthcare and this is together with japan this
is the highest lifespan average lifespan you have
in in the world so compare it with like 18 percent
that we spend here so that's that's one two is we
need to accept that um to stay on longevity breach
and enjoy all these technologies
that i have in a near horizon
in horizon 2 which will be available to us widely
in 5 10 15 years you need to make a change today
right to be healthy and happy in 15 years time to
enjoy all of this and a lot of these choices are
about your your own lifestyle so what is your
diet what is the level of physical activity
how peaceful is your mind because every time we
talk about our own health we tend to defer to
physical health while mental is is equally
important to that so that's why when
when we do a change program for huge corporation
and again it's all pro bono um everything i do in
longevity is is me sharing the best of me with the
world um so when we do a program like a corporate
longevity program the largest i've done was three
for 300 000 people in like 29 countries uh we just
work through the five buckets one is uh like
annual checkup and and any composition of this
has changed dramatically in the last five years
um bad habits like no smoking you know no alcohol
a lot of this kind of stupid mistakes that we do
in terms of the bad habits third is about diet
changing everything in the vending machines in the
canteen so people have uh more plant-based choices
and i was also actually insisting that they have
like uh vegetables fridays and mondays but uh
i haven't find any big company who are just
comfortable with with you know narrowing down
the choice to vegetables only but i'm you know
this is it's tough we can't get the fast food
restaurants out of a lot of the hospitals oh yeah
it's insane right yeah or schools right yeah so
that's the third one fourth is physical activity
leveraging variables even the current version of
whoops or feed beats or apple watch um to measure
uh the steps like 10 000 steps a day and it
builds up like department by department business
unit to business unit country competing with
country who's done more steps that's exciting
and thief is is um peace of mind which is a lot
of things i call it think and grow young which
is sleep and i know you have matthew walker on
your podcast his book changed my whole approach
to sleep i i was just crazy right it is like i
was just looking at my sleep hours as like
endless credit where i can borrow the hours
and apparently i think this research came up
like last month that if you sleep like five to
six hours a day your chances to get alzheimer's
like 40 percent higher so then it's meditation
because we all have extremely high cortisol
level our body and mind were never designed
to handle amount of stress that we have here and
like having access to constantly negative news
that we have around us um is pretty bad and
then it's a lot of different things like act
of kindness sense of purpose that you that you
have it's it's very important as well so it's it's
a little bit longer answer but you know all of
these five buckets are important as well because
human body and mind um are probably
the most complex thing on this planet
and yet the uh sorry that steppenwolf was there
but but of the protocols you just mentioned
they're all very rudimentary elementary simple
things that we can do now we can talk about all
the crazy future devices and wearables and the you
know genetic engineering that we're going to get
into but fundamentally right now do these things
take care of yourself in the best way that you
know how to and most people are already aware on
some level of all of these things it's a matter of
implementing them into your life but the one piece
the one the one bucket there that you mentioned
that i'm not sure we've talked enough about
at least on this podcast is this idea of
of um of getting these you know consistently
getting checkups so that if you have a problem
you're in an early detection phase and i think
that's in part informed by on some level a
distrust of the medical establishment i mean your
own personal story of going to the doctor and just
being prescribed like you take this and you're
good the inquiry doesn't really extend beyond that
right hopefully as scanning and you know testing
diagnostics improve we'll be better at that early
detection phase but i just know for myself i'm
like when i go to the doctor he's going to take my
blood he's going to say whatever i'm like what am
i really gonna get out of that am i really gonna
uh you know put myself in a position where if
i do have some latent condition and it's early
phase that it will even be detected yeah so things
have changed dramatically in in this field like
right now i mean you can do like full body mri and
the current version of these devices is like as
precise as possible they actually upgrade the
the software there every six months so just a
few years ago when i started to do my checkups um
it was radiologists looking through my scans and
human being without support from computer uh
is successful in terms of detecting probably
yeah as far as i recall 38 of early stage cancer
cases just based on the review of the scans but if
you empower this radiologist with artificial
intelligence and it's not i it's not either
or it's not mutually exclusive like people
think it's actually a combination of human
and artificial intelligence success rate is 98
to 99 well that's that's amazing and it's also
it's becoming less invasive right just a few
years to check colon cancer it's like a few
thousand dollars procedure it's invasive you do
it under sedation right now we have cola guard 19
and that's it and it's it's as precise as
um as the procedure you do a few years ago
and uh it's just amazing how you know like for 19
dollars how you can avoid like one of the largest
risk of your life get any colon cancer because
usually it's manifest itself at a very late stage
so a lot of discoveries is actually stage four
cancer when uh recovery rates are uh very low
and or this thing like you know zeo patch
which will kind of measure uh the work of
your heart so i do think it's time for us
to change our view on on what is actually um
almost any healthcare provider has to offer to us
because of this speed of technological development
and scientific development is just accelerating
right it is crazy how humans i mean once you if
you were to get cancer you would spend any amount
of money that you have in order to eradicate it
but we won't spend the nineteen dollars for
the test yeah it's yeah i i actually find it
really counterintuitive and uh every proactive
treatment is at least 10 to 20 times cheaper
than treating like post factum treating disease
at the late stage one and then recovery rates
like in terms of impact on on the quality of
your life it's just amazing so my father had
lung cancer back in 2005. and he survived
but a guy just shrunk in size by one-third
and his quality of life never recovered and and
this isn't not the type of longevity that we all
you know want to have so we just influence our
um health uh in an advanced manner well this
well that's one when it's this separate issue
and separate aspect of that i don't want to if
you want to go to that the version of medicine
that you will find in the hospital next door
is 17 years old well that's that's
the time between approval of something
until it gets kind of distributed and available
in the healthcare system so think about you just
you go there and like what is offered to you
is dated what in year 2000 well that's another
problem i'm still kind of thinking how to solve it
but again it is about different players disrupting
this whole thing it's not about making efficient
current systems yeah sure so you can't you can't
just focus on the technological innovation
without tackling the regulatory landscape i
mean that is those things go hand in hand because
uh you'll never get out of the gate with anything
in terms of you know implementation if you
can't deal with the regulatory and that's
perhaps the bigger hurdle here you
do have all these startup companies
who are coming on board i presume
a lot of them will end up getting
absorbed by the larger tech companies as they
consolidate here um but the governmental piece
is is really the the mount everest of enacting
positive change yeah that's true well the biggest
change that we can do is just accept in in
regulatory terms accepting aging is disease
because this will give you like a framework for
investment because i'm always saying that that
longevity and age reversal is like a next cancer
case we're right in the middle of winning the war
against cancer you think about 20 years ago people
were deferring the deferring the date of their
uh cancer screening because if they had a
cancer it's almost like piece of that yeah
that that's there's a psychological piece there
yeah yeah most people are just like i don't want
to know you know or i'm too afraid to find out
because then suddenly my life's going to change
it's not the case anymore uh so we again early
stage cancer diagnosis gives you 93 to 100
chances to recover and we still have this kind
of old 20 years old mentality to face that
well you're talking about classifying aging as a
disease that's something i talked about with david
on the show about i mean there's a hurdle in just
getting people's minds around that right which is
i would suspect one reason why you want to go to
a smaller country like singapore or what have you
where you can run kind of a pilot program um
easier to you know sort of test the waters and
enact change in a smaller situation rather than
just you know trying to combat the powers that be
in washington yeah that's true right kind of
like how is it el salvador or ecuador where
bitcoin just became like legal tender yeah like
it's just you know do it in a smaller country
and then you know the dominoes begin to fall from
there yeah but on that idea of aging as a disease
like where are we in terms like if you go to
capitol hill and you're you know testifying before
congress on these issues like getting those people
to wrap their heads around that i mean good luck
oh yeah it was probably the most difficult
challenge that i've a challenge i've ever faced
and and we we all longevity related uh scientific
and technological community are struggling
with that and um again i still don't know the
answer uh but what i do know that with the age
your chances to get heart disease cancer
diabetes are exponentially higher look
at the recent covet example unfortunately covet
were detrimental for the old part of population
so this there's a clear case behind it because if
you go to walgreens or cvs today and you ask for
drug against aging they would think you're crazy
or they would send you to cosmetics or supplements
and and this is counterintuitive so i do think we
would need to change it good news i think it was
back in 2018 world health organization actually
uh had a special code for for aging and like
age-related diseases risk in its global
uh like a territory of uh diseases and i
do think with just consistent work in terms of
establishing dialogue with with washington dc
uh and what fda or uh any other government bodies
uh has to offer and has to listen it's just it's
gonna be there so i don't really know when will
happen if you ask me i do think there's just some
few smaller countries in the world will accept
this i will create the viable economic model for
investments in longevity and this will happen
because cancer today is 100 billion dollars of
research and development money funded every year
to fight cancer and that's why 6 out of 10 u.s
biggest revenue drugs are oncology
drugs back in 2008 it was statins
remember my story viagra and only one on culture
drug right now it's six out of ten so the same
should happen in in fighting aging and age-related
disease right now longevity is one or two billion
uh dollar investments every year so when i set up
longevity vision fund with hundred million dollars
this is not my money this is money of investors
um people thought you know we just crazy we became
imagine largest longevity focused fund in the
world with 100 million in financial industry terms
this is the most insignificant amount of money
they can have and again people thought we just uh
we're doing a lot of stupid things but things have
changed in the last two to three years and again
i agree with your reach that kovit has accelerated
a lot of the mind shift and basically created a
showcase of so many different technologies which
can help us from various genome sequencing that
we've done in couple of days yeah right and that
was the next thing i wanted to talk about the
other piece you know in this near horizon in
this effort to kind of normalize the idea of
of of growing to 150 years old in addition to
the wearables and the big data sets and the early
um the diagno the diagnostics and the early
detection is this genetic engineering piece
yeah so before we go into like technological and
and scientific aspect of that this there's a huge
ethical debate and trade-offs that we need to sort
out before we actually embrace uh that in fact my
belief that in 10 20 years time when the science
and technology will be there ethics and regulation
will not be there to embrace and accept that
that's that's going to be our biggest obstacles
and that's why morality of immortality discussion
is so important how do we need to change the world
for us to embrace the idea of living longer again
separate topic so think about what has happened
in in gene editing and gene therapy front in the
last 10 to 20 years we've been able to sequence
our genome we right now we know 3 000 genes which
are responsible for the aging processes in our
body and just uh probably decades ago chin therapy
was a tool to help people with the rare genetic
diseases some of them it was group of hundred or
200 people all around the world suffering from
this extremely rare genetic disease so this is
where we were uh 10 plus years from now so then
probably five years uh ago we the the portfolio
of gene therapies against rare genetic disease
really expanded again against rare disease
so right now we can help 400 million people
who suffer from rare diseases all around the
world it's called rare but it's not rare at all
it's 400 million people on this planet that's
a lot and then we just see in the cases of
gene therapy addressing much broader issues
like vaccines that we that we have against covet
are typical example of gene therapy we just
don't recognize that this is the move which
can help us to happen uh to and to address covet
or the there's the other drug i don't want to
gonna mention its name which lows your cholesterol
level not statin you just do this every six months
and uh it's the addressable market for that is
40 of people on this planet who has elevated
cholesterol level um so we just in the course
of 10 plus years we've moved from something very
niche risky uh to the tool and any technology
which can help half of the planet and this is
how fast uh the pace of of the progress uh is
but again uh when i think about gene editing and
gene therapy i'm more focused on helping people
who suffer rather than going into in a sci-fi
territory yeah yeah yeah when people think you
know i mean this is a part of it we might have
to have the morality discussion sooner rather
than yeah because it it it really does impact
everything that we're talking about i mean
when you're talking about genetic engineering
it wasn't that long ago where it cost billions
of dollars to do this mapping and now it's very
cheap and fast and affordable but it continues
to you know grow and expand and and evolve and
now we're into this prime editing phase of it
right which is kind of the the evolution of
explain what that is because it's pretty wild
yeah so this there's a number of um okay so we
can when we talk about gene editing we have
um uh the technology which is uh in use is
like a crispr so that's like uh um almost like
genetic scissors which cut the part of your
dna which is not working and replace it with the
with the other while it's it's it's it's been
basically a revolution in terms of uh our
ability to uh change our genetic code there's
so many different technologies which has been
developed since that right for example like speak
to david sinclair he is a big fan of epigenetic
reprogramming and and the fact is that you don't
really need to change the composition of dna
you can just silence or in opposite uh give an
opportunity to certain genes to express itself and
that's that's a nicer and more safe way to address
your genetic uh problem or well the way genes are
like at influencing what is happening in our body
is just uh you know proteins right the creation
of different proteins with the different functions
so you can have like a viral vector well that's
the actual term which just goes into the cell with
uh with with the different genetic materials
which produce the protein which you're missing in
your body which can be which which basically the
trigger for disease or your dysfunction or your
shorter life etc so and it's and there's so many
things happening in gene editing and gene therapy
uh world like you can take take your immune cells
like t cells and reprogram them outside human body
it will be yours so and then you just uh you
know make sure it it uh they come back to you
um and uh and they fight cancer this is
like the definition of uh immune oncology
and i know quite a few of people who actually
weren't really untreatable 10 years ago
but right now with this personalized version
of genetic and when you're on t cells fighting
your own cancer cells it's it's just really
mind-blowing yeah i mean there it's this weird
stew of miraculous and terrifying because the
idea that we're going in and we're snipping dna
or we're you know muting or silencing
certain sequences and activating others
it just makes me there's a part of me that cringes
inside because behind it all there is a certain
you know uh human spirit to be celebrated but
also a hubris that i'm not sure is as checked as
maybe it should be you know what i mean we always
go into these things thinking well it's it's a
binary thing we turn this gene off or whatever it
is and it'll have this a to b kind of impact but
we're not very good at looking at at these things
from a more holistic perspective and realizing
all the downstream implications of these things
that we just didn't understand or realize because
we you know we jumped before we stopped so i
do believe in the collective wisdom and you are
not alone so if you ask i think it was a study
done five years ago in use us in the uk so when
people has been offered to chance to uh extend
their lifespan if they can by 10 or 20 years so
we've got more than 65 percent people say no so
even if you say it's healthy and happy years we
have a lot of limiting beliefs and it's a lot of
things that we even don't know what we don't know
about this whole thing so one of the challenges
in our space is like how do we define that how do
we communicate that this is an opportunity how do
we manage the risk and uh again as i say uh in the
morality of immortality chapter we have created
technologies to extend our life but we haven't
created a life that we want to extend and there's
so many ethical trade-offs that we need to solve
in terms of the our own health and in terms of
the health of the planet before the idea of life
extension will be interesting and positive for
you and for so many people and here in the u.s or
people on the planet i mean i know you're an
optimist with all of this stuff but when i kind
of cast my gaze across history i don't see human
beings being very good at at grappling with the
ethical implications of technological innovation
because it's almost as if it's our biological
imperative to continue to iterate and invent and
progress and we give lip service to the idea of
should we or should we not do this but ultimately
it's going to happen no matter what right and i'd
like to think that yes we're going to put together
a manhattan project type brain trust to really
think about you know the profound unbelievably
profound implications of this vein of science
and hopefully there's lots of smart people like
yourself who are thinking about this and and
working on it but it's so intertwined with every
other challenge that we're facing and every other
you know existential threat to the future of the
planet and humanity that i can easily descend into
a more despairing view of how this is going
to play out i agree so world shouldn't consist
of sergey youngs yeah i'm because i'm like
super optimistic guy you know i need to be
super optimistic to fight the problem which we
haven't sold through the history of evolution
or uh the history of science right uh so that's
one there's always a the we need a balancing act
from the public right from uh people who are much
more skeptical about this because they are not
coming up with answers they coming up with great
questions and this is what we so my concern is
that we're working on this science and technology
of that and no one is working on the ethical side
right and please don't make you know make me
responsible for that i think it's our common
problem and i also agree with yurich that we
don't have a choice i mean this is happening it's
not like you we can sit down and decide what is
going to happen and we will just accept the fact
that or you know approve this whole thing this is
happening silver tsunami is happening development
of gene editing and gene therapy technologies is
happening increase of the lifespan is happening
100 years ago the average lifespan on earth was
what 35 years right now it's again for developed
uh uh countries it's 75. no one ever had a
debate like can we allow this to happen or not so
in a way this is a trajectory and and
what i what i would like to do is for
us to start a conversation start a thinking
process about how the world should change
how our relationship with mother nature should
change how our ethical norms social constructs
needs to change i would nominate you've
all know a harare to be in charge of that
inquiry yeah but we need to have a diversity
of uh uh opinions i think you all has a little
bit more uh like a dramatic view of our future
specifically uh just which derives from change in
uh healthcare like genetic uh gene editing
technologies but again i mean it's not up to
me to decide but it's just it's our collective
problem it's our collective discussion it's our
collective choice right right yeah and the same
goes to again like using plastics or allowing
dictatorships to happen or just how we
think about social constructs like marriage
all of which are in play and in flux yeah as these
technologies become more mature i mean beyond this
this you know shorter shorter window this shorter
horizon you know the other section of your book is
about this uh more expanded horizon of things that
you know are going to be they're kind of in their
in their infant state that you're predicting are
going to be realities and i don't know how long
the window is here but it gets pretty crazy right
it is we're talking about you know not just things
like organ regeneration and you know growing new
body parts like the way that we're cultivating
cellular meat right now but uh the idea of
tele-existence and ai brain integration and
uploading your consciousness to the cloud like
the stuff that is truly of science fiction and
some kind of utopian philip dick meets aubrey
de grey scenario yeah but it's just like well
let's just balance that so imagine our
conversation happening back in 1990
we like we really i mean we humans are really
bad with like predicting the future so in a way
my i don't want to predict the future with
um which should be like as precise as 100
the only reason why i'm trying to predict the
future and highlight all these technologies is to
for us to start thinking and making these
choices today to make sure that we are
comfortable with you know all this scientific
technological societal progress that we have
because to solve a problem of plastic to solve
a problem of um industrial production of meat
you don't need to wait for 2050. it should be
solved right now and i'm happy there's just a
lot of technologies and and innovation
happening in the space like plant-based
meat right which is uh which will change the
landscape uh pretty significantly but again for
me it's a wake-up call like predicting the future
is a wake-up call that we need to have today
yeah i have bruce friedrich coming tomorrow
who's from this organization called the good
food institute oh yeah he's at the center of
this whole yeah and plant-based meals we need
more people like that um indeed but
on this idea like it's such an amazing
provocative i call it a thought experiment you
would call it a future reality to just consider
the implications of living to 200 and beyond
that the the possibility of being immortal i
mean these are questions that humanity is reckoned
with and wrestled with you know as far as we've
been a thing right and the idea of should we
is is really amazing right and you kind of
walk through like let's have the ethical
conversation like should we do this like
what happens to humanity what happens to the
human psyche when you wake up in the morning
and you have a choice for just how long yeah you
want to live yeah there's a few things there um
one i i just wanted to be upfront i'm not a big
fan of immortality right because i do think if
you take out the death from the human life cycle
we are not going to be human life is meaningless
in life with its preciousness yeah exactly so
that's that's my thought well the second thought
i think it's very unlikely that we will have
a moment in our life when we will reach the
point when when you just in one day you decide
are you going to be immortal or not it's going
to be serious of your life extension decisions
which you do like every 5 to ten years uh so
let's change your perspective you would actually
be much more in control to defining the quantity
but also the quality of your life so this this
is what's gonna happen um in the future which
actually raises one of the questions that that i
ask uh in the book um so your decision to extend
your life or not is considered in our society
and culture is considered suicide or playing god
and then my my related question like will we have
like a bravery to make this decision you know when
i think about this in my own terms i would just
hate the idea of like you know i need to decide
on my own about this so that's this
actually you know makes my mind tired
imagine yeah unless you're in that situation
yeah how you would process it yeah exactly so
that's just and it's again it's just one of the
questions there's more of that so if we're going
to be living 200 years for example like paint
the picture of what this looks like yeah uh
so then so what's going to happen uh with our
marriages so right now depending on the country
two-thirds of the marriages going through divorce
in the first three five or seven years after the
uh wedding so what will happen with uh with the
family right with with marriage's institution will
we consider more like a kids-raising partnership
thing uh and again i i don't know the answer
for 150 years yeah so it's it's very
difficult to imagine so and and this
is or think about your career should our
life consist of several beautiful mini lives
well that's uh that's the question and and just
a lot of constructs in our society are not really
supporting this this whole idea of the longer life
and i do think since as we discussed our lifespan
increased uh twofold in the last hundred years
i don't we've done any kind of rethinking on how
our society is structured on uh in this regard
yeah i mean there's so many questions there is
the question of of you know what is the meaning
of all of this if it proceeds indefinitely like
what is god what is faith yeah there's the more
practical considerations of how does this impact
the environment this is my favorite you know a
limited amount of resources we're talking about
living longer which means more people you have a
whole thing about you know reducing the the birth
rate and this notion that actually population's
going to decrease which i struggle with you
know comprehending or not really cleaning or
agreeing with it so um so let's just talk a
little bit about this so there's a good study
uh i think published last well early last year
uh so if you look at reproduction rates all around
the planet we for every women um it's below two
so that's basically less than you know kind of two
kids per family in i don't remember the figure for
us but it's probably somewhere around 1.5 like in
some of the places like poland it's actually 1.3
so we are if you look at you and you put all of
this in in a mathematical model um the population
of earth gonna peak that somewhere around 10 or
11 billion by year 2050 and then it's going to
decrease the china will lose uh will it will
population of china going to decrease from
1.4 billion to 800 million people uh by the end
of this century and and the same will happen
everywhere with the exception of africa they still
have african continents and countries there they
still have pretty high uh reproduction rates that
foundation the foundation of that idea is premised
on raising the standard of living right like the
more that you educate people the more that you
and this is why paul hawkins big thing in drawdown
is educating girls so the more educated the women
are the less likely they are to have children so
as you raise that floor then you're looking at
one or two kids at most if you get it down to one
then we're in a declining population yeah well if
you're going down two because remember they need
to do a job like for uh her and her husband right
and obviously there's there's a different trend we
we can see we see decoupling like our reproductive
function from our kind of life it's just a lot of
technological front in terms of um our ability to
have babies without actually you know being your
like mother of this but what i was about to say
is um this whole thing is is happening and um our
reproduction race has been in decline and simply
because people have more choice there's just more
alternatives and it's it's good that they they're
using that but again it's you don't want to live
in the world like i think it was singapore figure
like 25 of the people of population of singapore
is already 65 plus so you need to respond and some
same happening in japan same will happen in u.s
so we need to work with the increasing quality of
life of the people who are in in all stage and the
way to address that is is addressing health span
because we need to increase health span in
parallel with with what is happening now we
increase of the lifespan as well so that's
one and there's external component to that
your own health is important but the
health of the planet is important as well
because many of us behave in a way that we
just ignore we don't take responsibility
for what what's our relationship with mother
nature is because simply the old mentality is
like you know i will not be alive then yeah
and and this thing will be sorted out by my
kind of kids and and grandkids sure so the idea if
you're going to be around a lot longer than yeah
again remember i'm like ideally right so the
idea is getting that yeah the idea is that
if we face a problem that we're going to live
with consequences of our own action i think
this will drive a much larger uh feeling and sense
of responsibility for what we're doing so anyway
but if you're a dude and you're around for
200 years and you had a kid 50 years ago
who doesn't talk to you anymore maybe you
think maybe i should have another one right
or if you're a woman and you're in this future
situation that you're imagining where you could
actually toggle your biological age and you
know i want to be 25 or whatever and you're
fertile for 200 years are you only going
to have one or two kids yeah we're going
to have multiple generations of kids that's and
they're all going to be living that long yeah
so i don't know the math seems yeah so i've done
the math so i was just planning i'm visualizing
a lot because i do believe like my mantra is to
live 200 years in 25 years old body so that's
i'm a great believer of psychological aspect of
aging it's actually this changing to this paradigm
mental paradigm has changed my life a lot because
every morning i wake up i have like three fourth
of my life ahead of me i can dream i can think big
i can actually change the world in a positive way
but um so if if you think about this one um i do
so the math is if i'm going to have in my like 150
years old party uh so i just did a calculation
and if i will invite only immediate family
and immediate friends it's gonna be like
15 000 people party when i turn 150.
we'll be back in a sec but first if you dig
this podcast and i hope you dig this podcast
then i think you'll really enjoy my latest
book voicing change featuring excerpts from
poignant essays by and glorious photography
of some 50 of my favorite guests over the last
eight plus years of doing this thing this podcast
it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show and
copious wisdom shared therein all wrapped in a
hardcover coffee table form that provides a great
taste of what we do here at the rrp and serves
as a beautiful keepsake or gift for the ardent
fan the book is only and exclusively available
on our website signed copies are available and
we are shipping globally direct to any coffee
table on planet earth so to learn more and snag
your copy today visit richroll.com vc that's
richroll.com vc all right let's get back into it
one thing that comes to my mind when i the more
i think about this is the mental health piece of
this my instinct is that it would provoke an
existential crisis in many because in tandem
with these innovations will come basically an
economy driven by ai and robots who are performing
a lot of the jobs that we don't have and maybe we
have a universal basic income situation but like
where are people going to find meaning in their
lives and when they're going to be living so long
how do you anchor you know that that quest or
whatever it is that gets people excited when they
wake up in the morning to go out and be in the
world how does that how does that get anchored in
a timeline that has become so extended like
i i don't know that we're we can even predict
what that would feel like yeah i agree and um
again i can talk only in terms of opportunities
in the future which kind of this picture of
the future give us uh today i'm also again
i'm not really like the futurist who just like
embrace whatever will happen there for me it's
just important reason to have a discussion that
we have today and go through our choices but i
do think it's an opportunity for us for us and i
know it sounds idealistic to connect to ourselves
because i do believe that uh if you take out the
noise of the environment and our social norms and
social pressure we are much better we are much we
humans are kind okay so that's the opportunity to
relate to your heart to your mind to realize your
dreams to to do the things that you always were
dreaming of doing so that's um so that's my yeah
and uh opportunity talk i hear that well let's
talk about the economic implications of all of
this because the other piece which is kind of a
gattaca thing right or what was that other movie
where they were all up in like some orbiting
spacecraft where they were sleeping in pods and
i can't remember it but anyway you know as this
plays out in science fiction typically there's
going to be a huge underclass and there will be
the one percent who have access to this type of
technology to you know be if not immortal live
for a very long time in beautiful bodies and have
access to all of these privileges that the rest
of us don't the example that you you illustrate
in the book is or the kind of thought experiment
is the dictator who you know basically refuses
to step down is going to be there forever
yeah um the power differential and the economic
implications of this yeah so i do believe that
everything we've seen in terms of
scientific and technological progress
in the course of like every invention
in the course of 10 to 20 years
becoming like super affordable so think
about the smartphone example uh like a
seller of phone like 25 30 years ago it was
a thing which cost you like 10 000 dollars
probably more it was like super heavy uh right
now if you go to like electronic market in china
you're gonna pay like nine dollars for the working
version of the smartphone so that's why or you
think about cola guard example uh which helps to
identify colon cancer it's extremely early stage
well this is test which cost nineteen dollars
so i do believe that technological and and
scientific innovation give us an opportunity
not to kind of increase the gap but as also to
empower um and and bring technologies and
inventions which would improve everyone's life
but again like we just we keep coming back to
that uh i so my yeah i'm always it's it's funny so
i have a mission of changing one billion lives and
it's always going to be one person in the audience
who just stand up and and say sergey why only
one billion we have seven billion people on
the planet and you forgot about the rest so i i
like when people kind of make me responsible for
like whole problems of this world but in
a way i'm just i'm in a i'm on a mission
to bring affordable and accessible version of
health to everyone at the fraction of cost against
what we pay today think about you know even if we
and every technology that we invest in is like 10
20 times cheaper than today's equivalent so think
about us releasing like nine percent of us gdp
and spending on some other things right yeah
education housing helping you know making people
uh happier i think the opportunity is there and
i i don't really gonna accept the idea of well
sergey well this is your thought well let's just
like how are you gonna solve it i i accept that
idea guys there's something happening and this
is gonna happen whether we want it or not like
twofold increase of a lifespan that we've seen
in the last country well let's have a dialogue
let's be active let's be responsible let's make
sure we we take back control and responsibility
for our own health and the health of our planet
so that's the idea yeah in other words you're
confident that these difficult questions and
and problems that this will will bring up or
ourselves also solvable yeah yeah i do like
everything we solved so far right in human
history and we always have a tendency to look
like a negative side of things well we have always
have a tendency to think binary this is black
this is white this is mutually exclusive like
i'm i'm seeing a lot of doctors and and they're
like what will happen ai will replace me again
my premise is that it's all it's not mutually
exclusive it's actually very complimentary like
there's a company called intuitive surgical this
is huge company they produce um like surgical
roberts robots uh and and they are brilliant
in terms of you know doing surgeries on heart
and um it was the head of one of the clinics
a large uh modern clinic here in the u.s
so and they before they brought the first
surgical robot there was just a lot of
doctors who were just saying like this thing
will replace me imagine what has happened
so they bought these robots and they right now
they're doing four or five times more surgeries
that they've done before people are extremely
busy they hired like 50 more staff to handle the
new inflow of patients because the cost of the
decrease exponentially the success rate of this
uh increase exponentially so this is the type of
uh thing which is uh waiting for us that but so
coming back to your statement i do believe we will
sort it out but i do believe we will sort it out
not just sitting on waiting but taking active
positions and taking responsibility to solving
this and many other ethical questions right among
those ethical questions being privacy rights as we
as we you know sort of uh amp up the extent to
which we're you know making ourselves guinea pigs
or or available for all of this data which is then
being harvested where do our rights sit and if
we've learned anything from the you know advent
of big tech and the explosion of social media
not exactly you know the the organizations that
that we feel comfortable trusting with with having
our best interests when it comes to these issues
yeah yeah that's true well that's why we have um
more regulation there i think we need to represent
our interest in in a better way and specifically
structurally if you look at u.s on the business
side there's so many things happening on
like pan-american level or like on the global
level because you know google uh amazon facebook
or global companies and the level of regulation
is usually like on the state level or you know
on the country level so there's a huge structural
mismatch about like the power of regulators which
should represent our rights and our opinion and
the global nature and the scale of this business
right and so that's and and the relationship with
privacy rights changes based on country borders
oh yeah so that's well that's that's kind of
one thing um the other thing and i i know it
might sound unpopular for some of our audience we
already made this choice so i mean you're wearing
what whoop i'm wearing apple watch uh you know
and the convenience of of using that devices uh
for us are much bigger than any compromise
on on privacy that we get having said that
it does not mean that we shouldn't regulate
this we shouldn't be more protective about this
uh whole thing so in the end when i'm when i'm
having friendly conversation i'm telling people
you already made this choice but uh yeah that's
that's that it's unsatisfying to hear that though
because i feel like it shouldn't be on us and
just because we sort of mindlessly stumbled into
a situation when we really weren't fully apprised
of the implications of it we shouldn't have to
continue to pay that toll yeah yeah that's true
and well i agree with that and that's just another
question that we need to solve because i
don't wanna you know my like genetic data can
can put me in a very disadvantaged position in
terms of my ability to get affordable insurance
however affordable like version of
healthcare that we're trying to create
well it's just another uh ethical question and and
again that's why i think it's important to start
this discussion now and not to wait until this
will produce the undesired and disastrous outcome
the other really interesting question on this
on this ethics discussion is the future of
of evolution like what does natural selection
look like when we can purchase you know our our
longevity and that decision is based on economic
factors or access factors more than anything else
and the more i think about that the more it
appears clear that the evolutionary imperative
of the human being is to give birth to this
artificial intelligence that then becomes subject
to the laws of natural selection in a different
way right like we've kind of played ourselves out
and now much like you know some animal who who
is you know like a like a whatever analogy you
want to use like a caterpillar to a butterfly or
whatever we be we're becoming something else and
the book kind of you know basically illustrates
that yeah uh well that's uh yeah that's that's
an interesting uh thing to realize for us and um
i do believe however dramatic it sounds for us
but it's just a part of you know evolutionary
cycle and it's been always the case right and
no one you know animals didn't really sit down and
and discuss like will we allow uh homo sapiens no
we're doing it it doesn't matter what we think
about it like this is just what's happening
this is what we're going to do it is but also
the other thing rich which i wanted to mention
here don't you think it's happening already with
us saving people with uh i mean we're already
i mean our cell phones are you know they're
not they're not implanted into our brains but
you know most of us won't leave it won't go
anywhere without it it is an appendage yeah i'm
actually and there's another uh risky aspect of
that like um our over reliance on technology is i
do think it opens up the other risk area like you
know what will happen with uh if something will ah
just really like a black swan or something will
happen in terms of the ability of these devices
to operate like a huge electromagnetic wave from
the space something happening on the sun or so
yeah and we like unprepared to live in our
today's world when you can use your hands to
start your tomatoes as well yeah so then uh well
that's that's the other case but i do believe that
we changed the law of evolution many decades
ago when we with us and i'm i'm cool with that
you know saving people who would like hundred
years um ago would just die because of their
genetic disease or because they couldn't really
fight with virus uh this is happening and that's
why and i do believe if you want to be positive
about this i'm not sure you want but in in the
history of evolution this skill and the talent
which is required to to win an in evolutionary
process has been always different i mean in
one stage you you should be like super hunter
and the other stage you should just be good in
in agriculture in the other stage you should be
good in like working in a factory like repetitive
job uh right now you can have like diversity of
options like how you use your talent and and
you shouldn't really suffer because you were
unlucky in genetic lottery so i do believe we we
have more choices but again having more choices
gives you more like responsibility on your
shoulders which particular one you choose and how
like eco-friendly this for people around
you and the planet as we move towards these
digital avatars and tele-existence it
gets super crazy in terms of being able to
essentially be in two places at one time or
transport your consciousness and you know whether
or not we're going to be able to have brain
transplants or virtual reality experiences that
are so real that our physical bodies are no longer
carrying the meaning that we attribute to them
the extension of that moral landscape
inevitably leads to grappling with the very
nature of consciousness itself because that's
the one thing that humans will always protect
where is my consciousness where does
it live can it be transported and
if my body withers can it be you know basically
moved into something else right and in order to
figure that out we have to understand what
consciousness itself is right and that becomes
like a rabbit hole with no end yeah so how do
you think about those kind of questions yeah
um so again remember our main focus is
horizon 2 like what to make sure that we
have affordable and accessible version of
technologies in five to ten years from now
um but what i can say i just hate the idea of
us living in the virtual world i do believe that
yeah i would like us to enjoy ourselves as humans
in in in this in material world for uh as much as
possible so that's why we're not investing in uh
human avatars we were looking like what that is
for people so yeah so there's actually so our
idea was that okay well let's invest in human
avatars and and see how this technology can change
our life so we look at number of robotic avatars
company first there's two types of other one is
robotic avatar you have like a copy of the robot
and then you you basically you know could
send this robot only like a north pole or
to mars and uh and right here uh on the other
device you just have like the same experience
um just but not you know being present on
mars uh similar to what we've seen in an
avatar movie in fact i had an opportunity
to discuss the ethics of um of the future
and human avatars with peter jackson what did he
have to say yeah he is basically saying that that
we humans tend to dramatize the future
and the negative outcomes of technology
he says that we've been wired by mother nature to
look for negative stuff because this is your like
you're just managing the risk of existence yeah
uh in a way and he he always and this is what i
use as well he said like but just thinking about
people who would really need this like people who
just you know like do firefighting uh people who
wants to discover and do like scientific discovery
on mars but don't want to spend like three years
uh on a space shuttle like uh you know commuting
here and there uh people in need people who
are really disadvantaged in genetic lottery
and for them this is the opportunity to enjoy
life to have meaningful impact here so that's
uh that's his view so coming back to avatars
uh so we we were looking at this and apparently
the to my surprise and it was pretty shocking
but we find out that the other version of avatars
which virtual avatars is much cheaper to create
and we've seen examples then you can basically
uh like a recreate a person in the virtual world
world and it's much cheaper and again with a
different like vr ar technology you can actually
enjoy this uh there's a very interesting clip on
on youtube uh when south korean mother meeting
her daughter um well let's let's explain in
the book meeting her daughter who died in
the age of five because of the rare disease
in the virtual world it's eight hours sorry it's
eight minutes clip done by uh south korean tv
where mother actually meet this girl in in
a virtual environment i'm father of four
i basically stopped watching this after
first minute because i was just crying
it's heartbreaking so essentially a a digital
avatar of the daughter who had been passed away
was assembled using archival footage or just
like photos or videos and some kind of algorithm
yeah was able to figure out how this child would
act visually the mother exactly yeah and then 99
yeah yeah it is yeah so again it's just
heartbreaking uh so then the question is um
what are we gonna do with that and and that's why
we are not investing in avatar space because it
still can really handle the idea of efficiency of
the virtual world like i'm a it took like a couple
of years to my social media team to like push me
into social media to like linkedin uh facebook
instagram because my real life is so interesting
i don't wanna like create a virtual side of me
having said that well these are the technologies
that we we have so the unfortunate outcome of this
for me is that the speed and and efficiency
of virtual world provides more opportunities
for us to recreate ourselves and extend our
resource than than the material moral world
but again let's kind of think how peter jackson
addresses that uh he says okay well sergey um
who was like the man of the women uh who had
an enormous impact on your development when
you were young and i was always thinking about
um one of my uh granddads and uh i would love
to have an opportunity to have his advice in the
virtual world once a quarter when i'm really in
a kind of difficult life situation and there's
even a company i think it's called wisdom ai um
it was helping to recreate like an artificial
uh version of um uh you know particular uh role
models and for you to have an opportunity to
have a advice kind of through through the wisdom
of generations rather than trying to solve a
problem that you're completely unprepared to solve
so again there's always it's up to us
are we trying to use this technology
uh for good or for bad it's almost like
for nuclear energy right you can create a
nuclear bomb or you could you can create like
a nuclear energy plant uh for that or uh you
can use this for um creating the best version
of the health scanning device which will help
to save millions lives so that's it's it's all up
to us or we we ignorantly uh innovate our own uh
shelf life and you know we just we innovate
ourselves right out of of existence like you
know the terminator dystopia of ai becoming
sentient and you know humanity paying the
price i agree with all of this stuff well the way
our conversation goes uh i think i don't want to
you know be like a guy who just
embrace all of this uh i but i do want
so don't gonna kill the messenger right
i do want to say guys this is happening
we need to think about this we need to take
collective responsibility for our choices because
if you if you just let it let it be done by
default by market or commercial forces it's going
to be disastrous version of the future what's your
sense of how we accomplish that because i i do
think there needs to be a global congregation
of incredibly bright people philosophers
scientists technologists politicians people from
various walks of life who could contribute to
this brain trust of trying to figure out how
to responsibly usher in a technology that's
more powerful than anything we could possibly
imagine like as you're telling the story about the
the korean mother and the daughter i'm i'm i'm
starting to greater have a greater appreciation
for not just like when we're talking about
longevity and aging we're talking about time
right and our our our relationship with time
which is kind of a human conceit in many ways
like it's a it's a malleable conceit but when we
start talking about virtual worlds that changes
our relationship with space as well like and
distance and everything all the physical laws
that govern our daily lives suddenly become very
different and trying to really understand what
that means seems like a very difficult equation
to square it is well it's difficult for me as well
but i do think that every little step that
we can take just to increase awareness
of that that's important and educating
our regulators government people societies
is uh super important and i do believe that a
choice about a healthy version of our future
starts today so it comes down to well however
distant distant our problems that we just discuss
there's so many things that you can do today
like just re-establish your relationship with
mother nature make healthy choices in terms of are
you supporting industrial food production or are
you supporting organic food production are you
you know are you more plant-based and therefore
it's more friendly for your body and
for the planet for the communities and
and the health of the nation um are you uh doing
a lot of acts of kindness are you sharing the best
of you with the world and therefore you help
a lot of people to achieve their own potential
realization and social be like happy version of
of themselves because we need to be in healthy and
happy state to appreciate that today and to make
sure this healthy and happy state extends uh in
the future yeah i like that i mean that's all we
can do right now as individuals right on top of of
everything in here one thing we haven't gotten do
yet in this discussion around longevity isn't just
arresting the aging process it's this idea of i
mean it's literally the title of your book like
growing young like the reversal of aging so can
you kind of parse those two things when you say
growing young like what exactly are you talking
about yeah so um remember what we started is like
average lifespan on earth uh increased from what
35 to like or at least in developed countries
from 35 to like 75 years but then the upper limit
of uh lifespan is still the same it's somewhere
around 120 years yeah so the the oldest person
on earth was this beautiful french woman who died
i think back in 1999 in the age of 122 years and
this has been unchanged through the whole history
so uh then the question is um how do we change
that and so for the way we've done we increase our
lifespan and health span it's been avoiding early
deaths but that's like the only thing that we've
done and even the focus of today discussion is
like well let's just not die from cancer let's not
die from heart disease from diabetes we're facing
actually the next wave the next barrier which is
neurogenerative disease comes which uh come in
the latest stage of our life somewhere around 80s
or 90s which we still need to solve but it's again
it's just so the average lifespan increase because
we're avoiding early death so that's that's the
modus operandi because a lot of those stats are
driven by infant mortality exactly right exactly
well that's that's like the biggest uh problem
that we've been solving um so but what what what
is happening with the technologies and and science
breakthroughs which are uh available to us today
and which is in in like a working process today
we will soon have an ability to reverse aging
even like there was a very small studies done with
you know eight people who actually managed to
reverse their aging based on set of biomarkers
but a very small number but i i and again
it's it sounds impossible and ridiculous today
but this is actually happened you can grow
young you can change your set of biomarkers
to be younger like even today like when i s when
i had my studying story when i rejected the idea
of taking the appeal to the rest of my life
and changed my diet became plant-based uh doing
physical exercises uh taking omega-3 and there's
like even a vegan version of that available right
so you can be vegan and take in different
supplements i reduce my biological age by
probably three to five years so that's
this is already happening we just have
this lifestyle intervention and this will be
contributed and complemented by our ability to
influence genetic diseases or our genetic set
up our ability to regrow and replace organs
actually the most the two most difficult ones is
actually brain and heart isn't it symbolic and or
having longevity and appeal right we have so many
um longevity and and age-related disease kind of
um drug candidates at the moment like metformin
generic drug has been there for 50 60 years
brady's safe we still need to run a trial whether
what is that what is it um in terms of creating
age reversal effect right or life extension effect
but this is still uh in in development stage
but again there's there's a lot of ideas how we
can reverse our aging and some of these species
on earth they don't have an aging process so the
way they die is like metaphorically like you know
being hit by a boss right so there's no in terms
of our biological setup we don't necessarily need
to to age but again and this and i do think it
was the theme of our conversation today before
embracing technology and science of age reversal
there's much bigger issues that we need to solve
yeah create a life that we want to extend yeah
100 we like to talk a lot about the minutia or
the one percent that's gonna you know some
supplement that we can take but in truth the
real mover here is how you're living your life on
a daily basis exactly and it's not sexy it's not
you know there's no there's no hack involved with
that it's just you know good habits it's every day
practiced every single day i agree and i know that
i know that david is is you know a friend and a
colleague in all of this um david sinclair yeah
but one of the things that that um i wouldn't
say you disagree on but where you're a little bit
different in terms of focus is david you know he
loves to talk about sirtuins and regulating mdor
and resveratrol and foreman as you just mentioned
yeah nmn and nad and all that kind of i think it's
too early yeah yeah so yeah and and again i think
the mental trick what it does is you're gonna
start to believe in this magic pill which will
solve all the problem for you and the problem is
like rather than changing your life and the life
of people and health of people around you you're
just like waiting for this magic peel to arrive or
you can buy it in the form of anime or metformin
and and that's and and and i do think it's just
it changed your mentality rather than taking
responsibility and changing the world changing
your health you just like sit and wait until
something magical will happen and i'm a
little bit against that i'm also i also think i'm
chemical engineer by my first degree so that's why
you know i just rejected the idea of you know
having statins for the rest of my life and this
is where my longevity journey started i just do
believe that a lot of things need to be tested in
a proper way before we can embrace that and
in the meantime we just need to look at the
livers that we can uh actually control today
and we can change today so i i i think the
downside of believing in like magic peel or magic
supplement is that it's just another excuse for us
uh to be irresponsible yeah divorce away from
you from responsibility yeah i would agree with
that it's amazing how many things work well
in mice that they can't figure out how to make
in larger mammals you know because there's crazy
stuff happening with oh yeah yeah yeah they just i
think they extend it just in the research uh study
last week yeah like 28 or like 30 life extensions
right so well let's discuss that i do the
beauty of progress is that right now instead of
kind of working with animals right now
there's a lot of development in terms of
synthetic models like almost computerized model
or artificially grown biomaterial which will give
us an opportunity to do testing without actually
uh involving uh animals and i love that i also
like the fact that it's actually more precise
representation of humans uh so then you don't like
you know going to the nature and trying to pick
up like in a pretty cruel way someone who's gonna
replace and like diminish the risk of losing
human life you're creating the computer model like
or biological model where you can test like the
substance in a very well i think like eco-friendly
way so i i'm not sure um we you know put a lot
of emphasis on this in the book but i do think
it's important to realize that there's so many
ethical things and problems that we can solve by
looking at technological progress as an
opportunity to be you know more in uh
in harmony if you want in a balance with the world
uh around us so i'm not that kind of optimistic
about research which you know has been done uh on
animals i'm more optimistic i'm kind of future guy
and probably today guy so i'm more optimistic that
with with the progress which we having today we
can actually be do much faster more representative
trials without actually involving uh um animals
or uh other creatures on this planet who were
not designed to help us to extend our life
yeah yeah of course not um it's a mindset
or a mindset or a philosophical shift
to approach these problems from a perspective
of of balance and symbiosis as opposed to
we're the apex predator and we're just going to
lay our template on this planet and make it work
for our own self-interest which is really the
prevailing you know sensibility by which we've
you know pursued you know yeah uh life on earth
and and and so there is there is a little bit
of a uh um you know a spiritual awakening or a
mindset revolution that has that has to take place
to pursue the solution to these problems from
from that more kind of empathetic compassionate
perspective but one thing you mentioned that just
popped into my mind when you were talking about
again back to the south korean mother and the
daughter and the the the advent of virtual reality
and and and the like is this amazing opportunity
to expand the aperture on empathy because
so many of our problems and our conflicts are
driven by a lack of understanding of where someone
else is coming from or what their life experience
is and if you could put on a headset or tap into
some technology that would allow you to experience
what it's like to be in a syrian refugee camp yeah
or to swim with great white sharks under
the water what whatever the case may be
i think there's a potential that could unify
us in a way that that um would be very helpful
in solving some of these yeah i agree with you
and i think well if you want to i mean covet is
a disaster right but if you want to look at
the positive side of that because we stayed
home and we were driving less look at the amount
of uh biodiversity that we have around us bounce
back pretty good it just and it's it was just
a few months and like i'm living next to the
park just i've never seen the birds which i've
seen during the coffee i mean it's still there
they just sing every morning i wake up and i
just stay there it's just it's been so beautiful
and i do think it just shows us the opportunity
like if we are mindful about our choices today
mother nature will not wait for 10 or 20 years
like gene editing technology to give you a
kind of favor to give you like a positive feedback
and i love that so um yeah i don't know what i'm
kind of talking about i just got so excited about
this whole thing and just it's and again it's just
our opportunity to reconnect to be more human you
know to look at the positive side of us and not
only in relationship like human to human but also
in relationship with uh nature around us right
the holistic nature of it all yeah um of
the companies that your fund is invested in
what what's got you excited like what's
happening right now that we that people who
are listening might be interested in hearing
about yeah so um remember we discussed that
we can regrow organs and that's actually uh
a huge problem today like if you need a liver
transplantation you need to wait for six nine
twelve months a lot of people just gonna really
last for that long and it's 800 000 dollar
procedure and like rica and i think a lot of kind
of foreign organs in transplanted in human body
get rejected because of the autoimmune reaction
so like genesis is a company called in in
pittsburgh sorry um from pittsburgh based in
pittsburgh what they do they split the donor liver
in 50 to 70 pieces so that's not one donor helping
one recipient it's just one donor helping 50 to
70 people they use this very simple laparoscopic
operation they put it in in your lymph node
it's actually here uh that's like the best place
and the new liver uh regrows in your body taking
the function of your kind of existing liver
and supporting egg wow so well the lymph node or
the lymph tissue provides like the habitat for the
cells yeah yeah so crazy yeah and they're like i
i haven't checked it but like they're like stem
cell they like pluripotent stem cells or their
liver cells yeah this it's the liver cells they
obviously stimulate that and lymph node is good
because it's just intersection of so many like
fluids uh inside our body but what is important
they had like um 100 percent uh success but uh
they the human trial uh is already happening
so it's not like the technology that we need
to wait for like 10 years it can change the
thing and um and the opportunity for us to
replace unfunctioning organs right and increase
the quality of people who are like really suffer
today or like 3d bioprinting well that's that's
amazing yeah you can you don't need to like hunt
for organs you know at peaks or at other humans
right and this is like barbaric in the world yeah
i know there's a company in israel that's doing
3d printing of cultured meat i believe right now
for human consumption yeah it would logically
follow that at some point they'll figure out how
to how to 3d print or or or cell culture or human
heart yeah why is like i'm sure it's ridiculously
complicated but inevitably as technology unfolds
like why would that not be possible yeah i think
it would be possible right now like the problem is
like every organ is like super integrated in our
body right with comprehensive holistic system so
specifically for the heart you just need to print
just enormous amount of is it capillars like a
smaller vessels capillary yeah capillaries yeah
to integrate it and that's actually works against
you because the complexity of this 3d 3d model
like to be integrated in the body is that but
this is all solvable in like 10 20 years so yeah
and i think there's there's a number of cases in
today's conversation when our barbarian practices
right uh can be changed with the beauty and and
the progress uh of technology and science as well
and this is where i i see the opportunity so
lab grown meat is like super expensive today
uh so did what um like uh using sun for uh
generation for electricity generation solar power
solar power yeah thank you um was super expensive
20 or 30 years ago right now it's just like almost
everywhere so this is gonna happen i don't know
how the world will look like in 20 to 30 years
but i do think today is the time to decide yeah
how it's going to look which brings you to the
x prize so you're on the well i don't know what
you're exact yeah yeah i'm i'm an innovation board
of uh i'm a group of crazy people who would like
to solve world biggest problems through x prize
foundation yeah and the and and the focus being
on on this aging question right so so the idea is
you put it out to the world and technologists and
smart people come up with solutions and then you
and peter or a board of people make a decision
as to who gets these funds to pursue that idea uh
no well it's it's a little bit different so what
what we do and we've done probably two x prize um
competition with elon musk as well you go like
a guy like elon musk you take um well there is
an x prize earlier this year uh competition
you take like 100 million dollars from elon
you go to the world and say guys the first team
is going to create the technology for in this
case like carbon removal to remove remove co2
from the atmosphere in a minimal viable product
will get 100 million dollars it's a
little bit more complicated than this
because you have like a short list of
10 teams they get like 1 million each
and like the final team like the ultimate winner
will have like 100 million dollar and it's gonna
take the price so you have two three 400 teams all
around the world usually it's 50 plus countries
competing for this price using their own resources
their own ideas their own creativity their own
network to solve this big problem and and
it's been this is how we why we have uh
partly private space industry because the first
xprize right now we know it is the virgin galactic
was creation the first private spaceship and uh
or so the idea with a traversal xprize competition
and i'm i'm sponsoring the design of that is um we
combined like the most brilliant minds uh on the
planet like george george uh david sinclair aubrey
the grace steve warwick the inventor of the first
biological clocks when you use a set of
biomarkers to define your biological age
and we design in the competition where you
have a set of biomarkers and it's like an
intervention or the drug or technology or the
piece of science who will help you to kind of
not to um age right or even reverse your set of
biomarkers in the in the course of um 12 months
in the current regulatory environment obviously
i mean to be safe uh it should fix the regulation
that we have uh today in in u.s so in the end it's
obviously it's just it's a big group of scientists
who's gonna decide like what are the ten most
promising and most effective technologies
or inventions which will help us to reverse
aging as a way to tackle age reversal diseases
and as a way to extend productive and efficient
stage of our life and then obviously they get like
a certain mini prices like a million dollars which
will which they will use to fund this second stage
of competition and like refine their own we call
it intervention intervention or technology or uh
scientific discovery and then the ultimate winner
can get a hundred million dollars so the beauty of
this idea this is all pro bono as you understand
um so the beauty of that you pay for result
and so we have like coral restoration x price now
they when they looking at the um challenge of uh
helping corals to uh to like regrow or we we just
finished i think it was back in 2019 the other
x prize with elon musk called global learning
xprize then we developed the well winning team
develop who won 15 million dollars developed
the app which is open source can be put on
any smartphone on tablet like the cheapest one
even the old one distributed to kids in africa
or people in prison for them with zero adult
support to become literate in english or swahili
in their own language uh in the course of 12
months isn't it beautiful when you have technology
right and and like the application which is free
for everyone for people to become like a wiser
and more talented and hopefully more kind
version of uh themselves that's very cool
can you talk about what's percolating up right now
what is percolating up is like what's the barrier
what no what is what are there i'm sure you're
like looking at submissions at the moment or what
i know we know so we actually looking for hundred
million dollars okay so you're putting it together
yeah yeah so i spent my personal money on the
design stage it took us like a year and a half uh
because uh well that's a pretty risky competition
to run we just want to make sure that um
we don't put an unnecessaries like human lives and
it's again human aging is such a complex problem
so it took us a while and quite a bit of money
again my personal contribution to that to design
the x prize so we're now in dialogue with few of
the sponsors who are actually happy to put uh 50
to 100 million dollars to uh support this prize
and if you look at the profile of these people
they all uh pretty reach and they at the
moment of of their life when they realize
you can't really take it all you know when you're
gonna die and like there's a limit of what you
can consume majority of them is like you know
i don't wanna yeah i don't wanna private plane
i'm like i just don't wanna you know i want to
change the world i want to make the world better
and that's if you think about this like you
know helping people to fight heart disease
cancer diabetes for the price of 100
million it's just incomparable with
economic effect with increase of our quality of
our life and increase of our efficiency and also
giving us the opportunity to dream more and and
just be you know more connected in this world
think that's a good place to end it but in
the meantime go outside eat more plants please
love your love your family love your neighbor
put your feet in the dirt right get a good
night's sleep and do your annual health child
checkups that's right cool man well thank you
thank you for talking to me today uh the book
is growing young the science and technology of
growing young you can pick it up everywhere
it's available august 24th 24th um and i
appreciate you coming to thank you i learned
a lot that was super fun so best of luck peace
you